we all know history is written with pens
bullets war is God's way of moving the
human race forward I'm here because the
future of the world is in peril because
of a man named Vandal Savage I chose you
eight to travel throughout time stop you
got the wrong euro in on my resume where
I'm from you aren't just considered
heroes to you shall we
you're just a lot assassin here's two
pair of good-for-nothing criminals like
the Luthor
we have the power to change our own fate
they're here DC's legends of tomorrow
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new
legends of tomorrow teaser so let's
break it down I've also got some news
about arrow in the flash - I'm also
starting a new round of the reverse
flash ring giveaway so all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video countdown
to 1 million so there are only two
things that stand out in this trailer
for me they're walking around the ship
the Waverider a little bit more I'll
have to talk about Waverider the
character whenever the series starts
he's not really involved with the series
but he's a big DC character the ship is
named after him it's just a really fun
Easter Egg but but the whole pitch for
the show is is that this ragtag group of
people not all of them considered heroes
have to save the world hero in in my
resume
seriously Captain Cold is one of the
best characters to come out of the flash
season 1 and that's largely due to the
writers and Wentworth Miller Wentworth
Miller is just amazing and all the stuff
he does but I feel like if you've
watched him in Prison Break then that's
a good barometer for how they're gonna
treat his character on legends of
tomorrow yeah he's a villain but he's
one of the protagonists Dominic Purcell
as heatwave is going to be the crazy
side of that equation he's the one that
balances out the Captain Cold hero
equation because Captain Cold like if
you watched the flash midseason finale
Captain Cold does bury a solid to square
the scales because he owes him one but
refuses to help him defeat the villains
he's like I'm not I'm not down with that
I don't want to be a hero Merry
Christmas
see you later Barry Barry calls [ __ ]
and he's like you wouldn't be here if
you didn't want to do something good so
that's just like the last step before
episode 1 of legends of tomorrow which
is actually almost here in four weeks
where rip hunter compels captain cold
and heat wave to come on the team now if
you are behind on your flash episodes
definitely watch season two just to kind
of catch up with the Captain Cold
character but if you want to read some
of the comics here just some
recommendations for good Captain Cold
stories so the modern version of Captain
Cold started his art in the John
Ostrander Suicide Squad which is
probably the best Suicide Squad run to
read it was vol 16 to 18 then his
payment for his service he gets parted
for previous crimes in the Rogues throw
him a party like a get out of jail party
in flash vol 2 number 19 and that's the
wally west run just guess who shows up
to crash the rose party yes the flash so
that's kind of the beginning of Captain
Cold in the modern Flash universe and
and this is the gun wielding Captain
colt this isn't like the new
- metahuman captain cold in flash 174
Wally West has to team up with Captain
Cold to take down tar pit tar pit is
actually coming on season two of the
flash so that actually be a good issue
to read there's actually a fun story
behind the tar pit character geoff johns
created him when he was like a little
kid then just kept redrawing him as he
got older then when he took over the
flash title from Mark Millar's started
writing Wally West himself he brought
tar pit in a couple other of his own
characters into the book ignition is a
really good story where Captain Cold
gets accused of a crime he didn't commit
in Wally West has to prove that he's
innocent so you see II see Captain Cold
works with the flash all the time they
have teamed up a lot in the past if you
guys watch the flash season 3 gorilla
city video that I posted earlier I
talked a little bit about legends of
tomorrow maybe running into the Legion
in a future season of legends of
tomorrow if you want to read like a
future rogue story it's called the
dastardly death of the Rogues that's the
name of the story basically at that
point in history in the 25th century
where they're from the rogues are good
they're like a team of cops and the
flash is bad if you haven't read
blackest night in a while blackest night
flash is also a really good captain cult
story where he has to take down some of
the rogues because they go rogue on the
Rogues and then I suppose you could read
some of the new 52 stories I'm not as
big a fan of the new 52 stories as I am
of like the pre new 52 like pre
flashpoint stories but suffice to say
you know Captain Cold one of the few
rogues who always ends up turning
against the Rogues to work with the
flash at the same time allowing him to
be somewhat of a villain like just you
know just because you're acting like a
hero doesn't mean you can't do bad
things he's he's more of an antihero
really the other big thing that struck
me in this trailer was when Vandal
Savage invoked the name of God and I'm
like well doesn't he worship Horus I
mean he started out as a priest of Horus
at least in the legends of tomorrow
universe so I'm like why is he using the
name of God he probably doesn't even
believe in him I kind of think they put
that line in there just to make it sound
badass because you know at a certain
point Vandal Savage would probably start
thinking of himself as a god but I think
the way they're presenting him at least
right now is sort of like this uh sure
for Humanity like I'm going to usher in
this new age using war is a catalyst
he's basically trying to speed up the
proliferation of nuclear war so
everybody get hyped is gonna be huge
what's gonna happen is is the flash is
coming back January 19th
arrow comes back the next day on the
20th and then legends of tomorrow starts
on the 24
and they'll just air each week Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday I recommend you watch
the episodes in that order and yes if
you're confused about flash and green
arrow they will cross over to legends of
tomorrow they just they're not in the
trail that much because they want to
focus on the new characters they want
you getting excited about the new
characters the other big thing I know
everybody's asking about is vixen
confirmed to be going on arrow like what
does this mean why isn't she going on
the other shows what if she gonna be
doing on arrow is it's gonna involve a
lot of magic just to back up a little
bit in case you missed it earlier this
year they did a six episode vixen
animated series on the CW see that's
like their digital streaming service
it's it's like CWC com they said that
they were using it as a litmus test for
the character she might get her own
series she might come on the live-action
series and they just confirmed recently
that she would be coming on arrow so
they chose option B she will have her
powers but we really don't know how
she's going to figure in in helping team
arrow fight damian darhk-- because
obviously that's a big magic art she's
going to have to help them because she
has magical powers now my guess is is
that it's gonna be kind of like the
constatine arc where it's like fairly
self-contained but it involves something
really important like Constantine left
he gave Oliver that special tattoo
that's a war that's gonna help protect
him in the flashbacks so I'm guessing
that vixen is going to show up in
present day I don't think that she's
gonna show up in the flashbacks I
haven't really heard anything about
vixen season two but if you want to
watch my videos from vixen season one
I'll add a link in the description there
were only six of them it was really
short what's gonna happen next is I'm
working on a new episode seven bonus
video about some of the the character
cameos while you wait for that you can
click here to learn all about the
Knights of Ren the group that kylo Ren
belongs to and you can click here for
the last Batman V Superman teaser
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
Oh